the search and knife crime in the
capital has brought tragedy to
communities across the city and in
questions to over who bears the blame
for the violence the culture that is
turning young men into killers
joining me in the studio now is the
community activist Stafford Scott
Stafford's good to see you just in terms
of the way in which this is being
reported a sergeant violence in London
maybe some people are questioning the
statistics but working in the
communities you do are we getting more
violence it will appear so that they're
getting more violent using violence more
often and that the outcome of the use of
that violence is more tragic and fatal
what are the police say it's not a
crisis that the government is quite
amazing why is it happening why is it
happening is because in 2011 the Prime
Minister Cameron and the Mayor of London
Boris Johnson stay either they were
starting a war on the gangs they then
had to create those gangs they said they
were starting to warn the gangs because
of the gangs involvement in those summer
riots four reviews including the
Metropolitan Police Services own review
said that there was no evidence of gang
orchestration Cameron and Johnson then
went on to help to create those gangs so
that we could have the narrative so that
the narrative that they gave us could
then appear to have some kind of
justification when you say that they did
they created the guy so I mean what what
do you mean by that man clearly there
were criminal gangs operating in London
before and Boris Johnson became a live
long ever being criminal gangs operating
in London since before John Peel set up
the police which is why John Peel felt
the police force there were some groups
of young people that we may consider to
be gangs but post the riots what the
government did was redefine what it
takes to make a gang when I was growing
up I heard about the craisins such I
learn about mobs of people who made up
gangs today this government is telling
us that three youths can be a gang I
have two brothers I come from a place
called Tottenham that means that these
people today would define myself and my
brothers as being members of a gang once
your stereotype has been in a gang and
stigmatized you just pushed out onto the
streets maybe you're clearly not
suggesting in any way that you know
drugs are not linked to the violence
that we're seeing in the streets let me
be absolutely clear this has nothing to
do with drugs whatsoever nothing to do
with jobs right now there is a war going
on in Haringey between young people from
Tottenham and young people from Wood
green that is nothing to do with drugs
is fueled by their way the way that they
tend to use social media more than it
has anything to do with drugs but
ultimately it comes from the pressure
that this state is putting onto these
young people these are children and the
state is using every single agency that
it has in its partnership to deliver or
not to deliver services to stereotype
stigmatize and criminalize these young
people and they're acting out as a
result of it it's not acceptable those
who are personally responsible should be
held to account but the state needs to
stop doing what it's doing because it's
criminalized in our community but but
not everyone who is part of those
communities is behaving in this fashion
and Posterous and was there is so what
was there are a number of very
legitimate historical reasons for the
black community in London to be to be
fearful of the police you know I come
from a part of the world which is no
stranger to violent crime
there's no stranger to drug abuse you
know who the dealers are in your
community you know who the people with
the guns are and you can see you know
the people with the knives are and what
I wonder whether or not those people who
are saying look the police have
alienated us you have acted against us
for so long whether that community is
doing all the decanted to tackle this
type of crime what can that community do
one of the things is that what we're
seeing at the moment is all of the state
agencies coming together and making
decisions they do not engage us they
don't talk with our communities you can
have ministers on after this program who
if I wait outside for them are gonna
phone the police and some are us in them
they'll run away from me rather than
engage with me so they don't talk to our
community so you don't think actually
the significant current police numbers
that we've seen in the streets not not
just of London but across the country
that that can't is not that that cotton
has not had an effect is not led to this
rise and no do you really and the policy
makers
really think that the kids are sitting
at home this morning watching this
program to learn that there's fewer
police and then thinking as a result of
that we're gonna go out there and do
something it doesn't matter the numbers
of the police it's about the pressure
that the state the oppressive state is
putting on these young people that's
making them respond in the way that they
are what response can there be to the
violence that we're seeing and it is a
significant upswing in violent crime we
can see across the board that crime has
come down over the past decade but in
terms of violent crime there are some
warning statistics what response to that
does not involve the police the police
have a role to play but this isn't only
about policing and that's the problem
local authorities central government the
mayor's office of all renée's on their
response abut each of these young people
there's no safeguarding there's no
proper recognition that black kids are
the victims as well as being the
perpetrator so all we get is policing
and the only response we get is that
kind of response we got from cressida
dick yesterday which is we're gonna be
harder and we're going to put more out
there which is gonna cause more response
code reaction but why then is it is it
wrong for some people and they have done
this to identify this as black on black
crime that whilst there is this this
rage and this anger amongst the young
disaffected communities that you're
talking about that rage is not being
directed against you know posh white men
you know in dispute against their very
own their employees almost like very
black men killing other young black
they're employed in new but the problem
is is that people gave it a tag a long
time ago and that's when they wanted to
start to deal with it differently from
how they would have dealt with it it was
just people young people killing young
people because they identified it as
black on black crime what they've
started to do is just bring in punitive
responses in in previous years gone by
say when we had the skinheads for
example the skinheads were committing
crime against other white people I
didn't call that white on white crime
they said it was a working-class subu
culture and that then it meant that we
responded to it differently there's a
range of interventions when they
dismissed it as a black on black crime
we got operation Trident a unit that is
as racist to the chorus any racist
who have ever seen and that very same
unit now is the gangs unit and that's
why we have this previous previous
position of just looking at young black
kids as gangsters